- All right,(indistinct) scouring the web
to find stories that
might brighten your day.
This Is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(Audience applauds)
Earlier we met LA's
first female Fire Chief.
She told us that she's often
come across dire situations
off duty and that her training
immediately kicks into gear.
And that's what happened
to Pasadena Fire Captain
last month just as he was about
to head out to a Rams game,
he saw go Rams.
(indistinct) he saw smoke
billowing in his neighborhood.
So he sprung into action,
ultimately rescuing a
woman from the second floor
along with her dog.
We have him on the line right now.
So everybody say hi to
Captain William Basulto
who watches on NBC4 Los Angeles at two.
(audience applauds)
- Hello hello how you doing?
Hi Kelly. Thanks for having me.
- Hi. So you're a hero, so
thank you for being that.
First of all, that was awesome.
(audience applauds)
- (indistinct) thank you very,
very much. I appreciate it.
- Take us back to that day.
What was happening?
- Well, it was a great day.
My father and I and son
were supposed to head out
to the NFC Championship Game.
We're gonna tailgate have a great old time
but while we're packing
the car and getting ready,
my father spotted a
fire across the street.
He pointed out.
I said, well, let me go see if I can help.
Headed over there
and I found a well
involved two story units
with my community members
running over there
with garden hoses and extinguishers.
So I got to direct them on what to do.
Break that window, put it there.
And at that point they
tell me somebody's trapped.
I look to the left.
I see a lady's screen
door facing gets a screen
trapped in the second
floor with heavy smoke.
I called out for a ladder.
They brought me a small ladder at first.
I was only able to reach
up to about my about here
and tell her stay low.
I'll take care of you.
I called out for another ladder.
I didn't hear any sirens.
So I called for 911.
And as I got off the phone with 911
to tell 'em we have a fire,
they brought me a second ladder.
I was able to throw it ladder
rescue the lady and her dog.
At that point, the fire
department showed up
and I was able to give the
Fire captain some lingo
on what I did and what I was doing.
And he looked at me like, who
is this Rams fan in Rams gear,
speaking the fire department lingo.
- (laughs)I love that.
So was the woman okay?
Was her dog okay?
- The dog survived.
The woman went to the hospital,
was there for a few days
a lot of smoke inhalation.
She was out feeling better
but the next day I did
get to meet the family,
the daughter, the father, her
father, and the daughter cried
in my arms and thanked me
for saving their mother.
But they were really distraught
that they had lost their home.
But at that point, the
committee had set up a GoFundMe
and everybody's been contributing to it.
- Oh, that's amazing.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much Captain Basulto
I'm liking your post right know alright.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, thank you.
- And that's not all,
our seasonal partner
Pilot Pen Makers of G2
that Go To Pen Of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna honor ultimate
overachievers just like you, sir.
So in your name, they're
gonna write a check
for a $ 1000 to help the
family who lost their home
in the fire.
- Thank you thank you thank you so much.
- Thank you so much sir.